was ich zur gesagt kann ich habe ein g
65 ja so gar nicht mit der angst waren
drei jahren ich hab ihm geht 65 also ich
finde das alles klappt muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen ich bin durch die welt
gereist wirklich durch die welt gereist
ich hab geküsst geknutscht alles jemand
ich dachte wenn du zurückkommst
nachfragen zum vom tal hat indien wo
überall ich war wie gesagt wenn ich
zurückkomme nach frankfurt du bist
definitely positiv es hat nicht
funktioniert ich wollte als genesen
sollte ich nein es hat nicht
funktioniert
ich mein ich bin 78 jahren versucht um
genesen zu werden also möglich es hat
nicht funktioniert so und ich glaube
auch wenn die grünen jetzt damit
anfangen
wieder verbote zu bringen die grünen
stehen jetzt einigermaßen gut da ja
hatte sogar die spd überholt da und ich
stehe jetzt sehr gut da ich würde es
sehr vorsichtig sagen da jetzt noch mal
anfangen mit verbote verbote verboten
die leute haben die schnauze voll
die haben wirklich die schnauze voll
klasse also das muss aufhören und ich
bin auch dafür dass hier wenn es sowas
kommt richtig demonstriert wird dass die
menschen auf die straße nicht 1000 2000
100.000 geht nach vorne und lasst euch
das nicht mehr gefallen es hat nichts
geholfen die zahlen ganz ehrlich in der
ganzen zeit in der ganzen maske tat habe
ich mir einmal eine mascara
hervor nein ich halte sie auch kaum auf
aber hier gab es immer ärger und strafen
in deutschland dafür daten sie sind den
in amerika da gab's keine strafen